technology will become a very important
part of nyu's global network University
the global network university is an
attempt in this technological century to
maintain human community and and the the
incarnated university even as we break
the time-space barrier by using
technology to permit connectivity in a
highly complex organism which is the
global network University so the the
fundamental premise is first that
technology is highly useful in breaking
that time-space continuum that we can
have a class that's going on
simultaneously in Abu Dhabi and New York
so a 9am class in New York is a 5pm
class in Abu Dhabi turns out to work
perfectly in the two cultures and you
have with immersive technology students
in both locations a professor in both
locations and the professor in New York
can see the student in Abu Dhabi raise
his or her hand can hear his or her
question and/or comment and can respond
to it and all the students in the class
in New York can be participating and
that can be networked in with other
students in Prague and Buenos Aires and
so on so so the technology breaks the
time-space continuum in a spectacular
way for us on the other hand the global
network university is an attempt to
incarnate on the site as well the human
interaction yes of a micro community
that's part of an organism which is the
the overarching community of NYU
worldwide but but that incarnate
presence allows for the human
interaction
that frequently is serendipitous so it's
the human interaction in the cafeteria
between a student that's working on a
project in discipline a and a student
who's studying discipline be where the
student and discipline be asks the
question just never gets asked by
anybody inside of discipline a because
they're so much caught up in the models
of their system and it tends to be the
question that challenges the first
premise and and and and asks does the
King have clothing on and and it
frequently can be the catalyst for the
most important idea that student a
thinks about utterly serendipitous
simply because they both sat down at the
same library table or they both sat down
at the same dinner table or they happen
to live in the same dorm and they're
discussing what each other is working on
of course there's much more formal stuff
to the interdisciplinary work and so
forth that goes on in a human community
and plus the the iterative conversations
that go on in a human community which
which may not go on in the same way in
technologically based communities
because one has to make an a priori
decision about to whom you're going to
speak and where you going to go for your
conversations and one tends to do that
in strange ways I mean this is an
analogy here to the way the two you know
just talk to a completely different
subject to make a point by analogy the
way the American public is getting its
political news today people choose to
get their political news from a place
that gives them the political news they
want to hear so we're in information
loops you know Mike my mind my Reagan
Republican cousins out in central Long
Island watch box you know and and they
get what they want to hear an end up
hating the Clintons no surprise
meanwhile there's you know the a liberal
counterpart to that you know which which
ends up with its QE II DS that are just
self referential and circular well the
the the the analogy of course is that
that if you become totally
technologically based it's very easy to
get in an information loop because you
go to the familiar and and this then
exacerbates disciplinary problems where
we're within disciplines there tend to
be divides that people end up speaking
to and cheering for each other and then
you end up losing the rigor of the
discipline and the real conversation
within a discipline then and the rear in
the conversation is the advantage that
caused our disciplines to grow I mean
the reason we have departments is
because by creating templates and
frameworks we we create rigor you have
to live to a certain stand well now
what's ended up happening is a in at
least in some disciplines people have
imported the functional equivalent of
Fox and MSNBC and depending upon whether
you want to think that McCain or Obama
is is the next coming you turn on the
channel you want well that's happening
somewhat in the disciplines and
technology if you if you don't also have
this incarnate serendipitous community
community is is is is likely to press in
that direction so so the global network
university is an attempt to get the best
of both worlds and and both break the
time-space continuum and allow the kind
of continuous conversation that the
technology allows wonderful and on the
other hand maintain the human element
which of course reaches its zenith in
the in the jesuit high school well done
you